okay let's talk a little bit about the
indiegogo crowdfunding fundraiser that
we have going on of course you can go to
david pakman.com slash donate to learn
more about that we are one week in and
we've raised ten percent of the money so
far the campaign ends on Donald Trump's
inauguration day you will be able to
until midnight on Donald Trump's
inauguration day uh be reviewing footage
of Trump swearing in his oath taking his
oath of office presumably on either the
Bible or a copy of art of the deal
written by Tony Schwartz with Donald
Trump's name on it of course and much
bigger letters uh and what we're really
trying to do here is significantly scale
up the coordination and impact of
independent progressive media we are uh
that we have the idea of creating a
progressive engagement coordinator that
will actually be working across
independent progressive media not only
with the david pakman show but with many
shows to really coordinate actual
activist actions whether it's
progressives getting involved in a
particular election campaign or whether
it's progressives getting involved with
a particular issue in making calls to
elected officials or to an organization
that is one aspect of this fundraiser
that were doing at david pakman.com
slash donate in addition to that a new
set design we've had the sort of black
backdrop with a couple of screens for a
while on the show and it's time to
really go to a more professional setup
now Rachel you were here when the set
design Pro came in I was super impressed
with him I mean he was measuring things
I can't even imagine the relevance of to
make really good proposals for our set
guy was a real pro it's a very niche
market but I think he's got it under
control yeah I mean that the you should
see the samples of sets that this guy
has worked on before and his company
builds from the ground up well as I
punch my Myka just so exciting I
couldn't help but punch my microphone uh
and the guy was uh he did a heck of a
job to quote George W Bush from from
years ago that's going to be part of
this campaign and also we are ready to
go with amazon prime once we have the
resources in place we've had a test
upload approved by the Amazon Prime team
and to make amazon
I'm a regular thing that's also
something that we need additional
resources for uh but it's so exciting
the possibility uh of being daily on
amazon prime and i know that that will
greatly expand our audience so all of
these things and more are part of this
campaign at david pakman.com slash
donate up popular perks so far the
bumper stickers available in both black
or white and or white very very popular
perks the 2017 david pakman show
calendar a very very popular perk
where's your calendar currently rachel
are you displaying it is it more of like
a personal calendar type of thing I put
it in my kitchen for anyone to come and
peruse it I think it's pretty popular
yeah I mean it's cert to call it a
conversation piece would be a drastic
understatement i would say flash drives
also available contributions of any size
seriously even if you can only donate a
few dollars don't just assume it doesn't
make a difference and not donate
contributions of all levels are not only
welcome but i really really appreciate
every single contribution nearly 200
individual contributions so far so let
me put a pause on that conversation
there and tell you that david pakman.com
slash donate that's how you pull up the
campaign and i hope that you will it's
gonna really be able to uh uh influence
how the next several years of
progressive media go